hey guys are you addicted to something
right now
I challenge you to be honest with
yourself
you might be addicted to something and
you don't even realize it
so how do you know well you test
yourself I want you to answer these
questions and answer them honestly
number one do you crave this thing every
week or even every day meaning you feel
that you can never get enough of it you
always want to do it again
two do you get irritated or anxious when
you can't do it
three
does it feel like you need to do this
thing in order to satisfy your craving
to feel better and More in control
four is this thing disrupting your
friendships or even your normal daily
routine
five do you tell yourself you won't do
it again
but then you turn around and you do the
exact same thing over and over again
now if you answered yes to most of these
questions then you are probably addicted
to something
especially if you answered yes to the
last question
you see addiction comes from sin it
comes from your sinful flesh it can get
so strong that it overpowers your own
will it is only God's spirit that can
help you to overcome it listen to Romans
7 15 for I do not understand my own
actions
for I do not do what I want but I do the
very thing I hate
you know Christians can especially feel
bad about this and even doubt their own
salvation because they've been trying to
overcome this through the soul level
their own will own emotions own
intellect
and they haven't been fighting through
this spirit so changing from the soul
level to the spiritual level fighting it
through that is the key to overcome any
sin and addiction
verse 17 says so now it is no longer I
who do it but sin that dwells within me
for I know that nothing good dwells in
me that is in my flesh
for I have the desire to do what is
right but not the ability to carry it
out
for I do not do the good I want but the
evil I do not want is what I keep on
doing
now if I do what I do not want it is no
longer I who do it but sin that dwells
within me
you see you are not the only person who
struggles with this Paul wrote about
this 2000 years ago already
and you need to understand that this
sinful condition in US human beings it
is a disease and you need to admit this
about yourself first
before you can overcome it
because the truth will set you free
he says in verse 21
so I find it to be a law that when I
want to do right evil lies close at hand
for I Delight in the law of God and my
inner being
but I see in my members another law
Waging War against the law of my mind
and making me captive to the law of sin
that dwells in my members you see it's a
you need to understand this it's a
Waging War in your mind making you
captive
you see sin is poison
and if you just leave it it leads and
grows into addiction
like pornography Jesus said in Matthew 5
27 you have heard that it was said You
shall not commit adultery but I say to
you that everyone who looks at a woman
with a lustful intent has already
committed adultery with her in his heart
is your right eye causes you to sin tear
it out and throw it away for it is
better that you lose one of your members
than that your whole body be thrown into
hell
so let's go with this example of
pornography watching porn is a sin God
is very serious and very direct about
this
and it can turn into addiction it works
like this you watch a little bit and
then a little bit more a little bit more
before you know it doing this sin this
sin starts to grow it takes root in your
mind more Roots Roots roots and it grows
it's it's living in your mind
it creates Pathways like the roots of a
tree the more you do it the more it
grows actions grow into habits then it
grows so much that it becomes part of
your routine
it is evil growing within you becoming
an addiction and that is what is so
important for people to stop sin before
it starts to take root in your life
and people who struggle with a certain
addiction for a long time that have many
roots many Pathways already in their
brain so all those Pathways in your mind
it disrupts your normal life your
relationships and every small root is
like an impulse that makes you want to
do that addiction
for example the moment you see a girl in
a bikini on Facebook or Instagram or
even in a TV show it immediately makes
you think about watching porn
now a lot of people think that they can
still overcome it when it is even this
strong they can still overcome it with
their own power their own willpower
if you think that
I need to tell you this you have already
lost the battle
if you don't change right now
because you cannot overcome it by
yourself
because yourself is already
wretched it has that sinful flesh in you
already
Paul says in verse 24 Wretched Man that
I am who will deliver me from this body
of death
you see now Paulie's on the right track
because he's saying man I am righteous
he understands that and now he's looking
outside of himself and asking who can
deliver Me From Myself
and then in verse 25 we see the answer
thanks be to God through Jesus Christ
Our Lord so then I myself serve the law
of God with my mind but with my flesh I
serve the law of sin
and directly in the next chapter he
continues and he says chapter 8 verse 1
there is therefore now no condemnation
for those who are in Christ Jesus for
the law of the spirit of life has set
you free in Christ Jesus from the law of
sin and death for God has done what the
law weakened by the flesh could not do
by sending his own son in the likeness
of sinful flesh and for sin he condemned
sin in the flesh in order that the
righteous requirement of the law might
be fulfilled in us and here it comes
listen closely
who walk not according to the flesh but
according to the spirit
you see that is part of the reason why
Jesus came to Earth to set us free from
our sin to give us the Holy Spirit when
we accept him as Lord and Savior so that
we have the power we need to overcome
sin
and that includes addiction Jesus said
in John 8 34 truly truly I say to you
everyone who practices sin is a slave to
sin the slave does not remain in the
house forever
the sun remains forever
so if the sun sets you free you will be
free indeed
so how do we fight with the spirit in us
against sin
well let's continue to read and the
answer will become clear Romans 8 5 for
those who live according to the flesh
said their minds on the things of the
flesh
but those who live according to the
spirit set their minds under things of
the spirit so you need to set your mind
on the things of the spirit you need to
study the word of God and you need to
let the Holy Spirit change your mind to
be thinking about the things of the
spirit let's continue verse 6 for to set
the mind on the flesh is death but to
set the mind on the spirit is life and
peace
for the mind that is set on the flesh is
hostile to God for it does not submit to
God's law indeed it cannot
you see when you want to overcome sin
and addiction through the flesh you
cannot do it
it is impossible
verse 8 those who are in the flesh
cannot please God
you see this is why people who battle
addiction like for example alcohol when
they are so tired of their addiction
regretting the destruction it brought on
their lives they look to God repent of
their sins and they accept Christ into
their life then in a lot of cases they
are freed from their addiction as well
we know that in Psychology converting to
Christianity is a proven treatment that
works for people who are addicted to
alcohol for example
according that is according to how they
see at a proven treatment but we know
the reality of it we know it is God that
comes and changes a person there they
are sick and tired of their old
lifestyle being addicted to alcohol and
the destruction it caused in their lives
and they reach out to God and they say
God help me
make me free
save me from all the things that I've
done I'm sorry I repent and I accept you
as Lord and Savior come and make me a
new person and God does it he gives his
spirit
that comes and lives inside of them
helping them to overcome that addiction
and they are freed
verse 9 says you however are not in the
flesh but in the spirit if in fact the
spirit of God dwells in you
meaning if you truly are a reborn
Christian God's spirit is in you there
are many people who say that they are
Christians but they are not they're just
practicing
Dead Man's religion they have never been
reborn spiritually reborn and this is
what he's talking about let's continue
anyone who does not have the spirit of
Christ does not belong to him verse 10
but if Christ is in you although the
body is dead because of sin the spirit
is life because of righteousness
if the spirit of him who raised Jesus
from the dead dwells in you he who
raised Christ Jesus from the dead will
also give life to your mortal bodies
through his Spirit who dwells in you
wow so first you need to learn how to
fight through the spirit through God's
power in you not through your own flesh
your own will your own emotions your own
intellect making your plans I've got to
do this and this is trying to fight it
on your own because you will not be
victorious you need to do it for God's
spirit and where you start is here
go and clean everything inside of you
go and repent of all the sin that you
have done ask God to forgive you
a purification needs to be done
1 John 1 verse 9 if we confess our sins
he is faithful and just to forgive us
our sins and to cleanse us
from all unrighteousness
so God cleans you he washes you clean
because of his blood he died for your
sins on the cross you accepted you're
asking God sorry that I drank so much
sorry that I watch pornography sorry
that I've let it took root in my life
you go and you be specific you ask him
father
revealed to me through the Holy Spirit
what do you want me to confess bring to
my mind everything that is wrong that is
in the way of me and you to walk forward
in righteousness and then you will see
now you remember this and then you ask
God to forgive this and then next is
another thing another thing another
thing you continue to do that until
there is nothing until you are clean
and then you move forward you trust his
word that says that if you ask him for
forgiveness he will forgive you you
don't go by our feelings
you leave the past because now you've
sorted it out you never have to think
about it again it is done God declare
just righteous
he forgave you because his word says it
so now you also need to forgive yourself
remember you live now according to the
spirit not according to the flesh
anymore
and you also need to go back and ask
forgiveness to those that you have hurt
everything you do now needs to be done
through the spirit
Galatians 5 or 16 says but I say walk by
the spirit and you will not gratify the
desires of the flesh
for the desires of the flesh are against
the spirit and the desires of the spirit
are against the flesh for these are
opposed to each other
to keep you from doing the things you
want to do
but if you are led by the spirit you are
not under the law
now the works of the flesh are evident
sexual immorality impurity sensuality
idolatry sorcery
enmity
strife
jealousy
fits of anger
rivalries
the sentience
divisions
Envy
drunkenness
orgies and things like these I warn you
as I warned you before that those who do
such things will not inherit the kingdom
of God
but the fruit of the spirit is love
joy peace patience
kindness
goodness
faithfulness
gentleness
self-control
against such things there is no law
and those who belong to Christ Jesus
have crucified the flesh with its
passions and desires do you see Jesus
did not just die on the cross for you he
wasn't just crucified for our sins
when you accepted him you decided to
turn away from your old sinful lifestyle
that old sinful lifestyle was crucified
with Jesus that's what it means when
you're baptized you died your old self
under the water when you come up
it symbolizes your new life in Jesus
Christ
read this with me again
and those who belong to Christ Jesus
have crucified the flesh with its
passions and desires
if we live by the spirit let us also
keep in step with the spirit
so how do you keep in step with the Holy
Spirit well first you need to educate
yourself you need to renew your mind
so you need to read scripture the logos
and then as you read it let the holy
spirit guide you through the Remo word
to talk to you through scripture the
church your brothers and sisters in
Christ as you grow spiritually this is
so important you need to grow into a
mature Christian
because over time you'll become stronger
so that you can handle the sin in your
life a lot better you need to live in
the truth in the spirit you need to live
it act it breathe it write it on your
heart you need to obey it and over time
you will grow spiritually stronger
with the armor of God that you need to
put on daily
you see
God is amazing he doesn't leave us alone
to go through these things by ourselves
because we cannot he is there with you
he will help you to grow spiritually but
it is your responsibility
to make time for God
remember new Christians especially they
look like spiritual babies it doesn't
look good you know imagine a grown-up
man walking around in a diaper
it doesn't look good you know it's not
supposed to be that way there are many
people who claim to be Christians for
years but they are still spiritual
babies and so they will always struggle
you don't want to stay like that a
spiritual baby you want to grow
in one Corinthians 3 verse 1 we read
but I Brothers could not address you as
spiritual people but as people of the
flesh as infants in Christ I fed you
with milk not solid food
for you are not ready for it and even
now you are not ready for you are still
of the flesh
there are still a lot of people out
there there are a lot of lukewarm
Christians who are not really Christians
at all but then there are a lot of
Christians who just sit at home on their
couches in their comfort positions they
don't grow spiritually they they kind of
stuck
and it is so sad to see that
he couldn't stay like that
do not be like those people grow in the
word grow in truth become spiritually
mature
when you read the Bible don't just let
it be informative
you need to act let it change over to
being obedient
to the word you know when you read the
Bible don't just read and say oh this is
interesting this is interesting no read
it in this way oh the Bible says I have
to do this I have to do this okay
how am I going to apply this in my life
am I doing this
how do you read the Bible or do you just
read it and it tells you oh I need to
tell Susan this I need to tell John
about this
no
the Bible is talking to you
God needs to be your first priority and
to study the word and listen to the Holy
Spirit and Obey him you will always have
a will on your soul level and this is
where God gives you the freedom to
choose how to live
but you need to choose to always let the
spirit guide you let me explain it to
you in a way that you can understand
if you go to the bathroom
the tap the water is there it's
available but you need to open it and
it's the same way you need to open
yourself so that the Holy Spirit can
flow through you if you do that
if you allow the holy spirit to guide
you your own emotions your will your
intellect man it's amazing because he
moves in righteousness in truth and then
you come along and your emotions your
will you your personality your attitude
starts to change
it becomes more like Christ your mind is
renewed it's beautiful
and if you do that you will always
produce the fruit of the spirit which is
love joy peace patience kindness
goodness faithfulness gentleness and
self-control according to Galatians 5
and this is important because
self-control you need to have
self-control to do what to overcome sin
and addiction remember God also says
that he has not given us a spirit of
fear don't fear this addiction or trying
to to fight it now with the spirit you
have to tackle it by the horns God has
not given us a spirit of fear
but a spirit of power love and
self-control
you need to act in this truth
so you have the power through Christ to
overcome addiction now you just need to
access this power every day put on the
armor of God and fight it because it is
going to be a battle every day you're
gonna need to battle your own fleshly
desires but also sometimes the devil and
his demons 1 Peter 5 8 says be sober
minded Be watchful your adversary the
devil prowls around like a roaring lion
seeking someone to devour
for some reason there are a lot of
Christians who are scared of the devil I
don't understand why because Jesus
Christ already won on the cross he's
Victorious you are victorious through
Jesus Christ meaning you have the
authority to rebuke the devil to resist
him and he will flee
you need to walk in this truth in
boldness
you pray for protection
you walk in this truth
and the devil stands no chance
James 4 7. submit yourselves therefore
to God resist the devil and he will not
maybe will flee from you
now a good thing that you can do is to
replace that addiction those habits with
something spiritual like every time you
want to do it when your flesh flesh
wants to do it you overcome it with the
spirit and you go and you pray or you
read the Bible
or you call even a friend and pray with
them
you know I've seen many men who are
totally healed of a lot of things
even depression
just because they went and prayed with a
brother and they brought everything out
and God came and heal them
the Bible says that you have to confess
your sins to each other so that you
might be healed
and part of that is a process where it's
a purification process that I talked
about earlier where you need to go and
you need to bring out everything
if you wash dishes you don't just wash
the outside right of a cup you wash the
inside clean before you use it again
it's the same thing you need to wash
yourself on the inside
and only God can do that with his blood
to wash you as wide as snow
go to God and you pray to him about all
the sin that you have done calling them
by name
for giving what people did to you what
you did to others
and you do that process with the Holy
Spirit
you can do this alone as well you go
into your bedroom door you close that
door where you are alone with God where
God sees you in secret and he will
listen to you and you say God please do
your work within me
search My Heart Lord and tell me through
your spread what I need to repent of I
want to be clean
pure before you
please help me to be psychologically
stable by sorting out my past once and
for all
please bring to my mind the things I
have not yet sorted out
if you have not done that then you have
to do that first and you can do it right
now after this video
and if you want to
understand better the difference between
the spirit and the Soul then please
watch this video here it's a little bit
older from my other channel but it will
definitely help you out
and always remember that life is short
so don't waste yours bye guys
thank you